To the untrained eye, SCP-2317 seems to be no
more than an old, wooden door. But those in
the know are more than aware that we have every
reason to fear this gateway to another world.
Specifically, the door opens to a desert-like
reality where a being known colloquially as The
Devourer of Worlds resides. When I say “resides”
I mean - it’s where he’s being held and bound by
ancient chains - for now. The Foundation is
forced to perform complex rituals in order to
ensure that the beast remains contained,
so it doesn’t escape and devour us all.
But there’s one big problem: The rituals
don’t work, the Foundation only performs
them to give their own employees a
false sense of security. Right now,
the Foundation doesn’t know how to keep the
Devourer reliably contained. What they do know
is, his chains are expected to break
some time over the next 30 years...